>> Laura: MY KIDS ARE COMING
TO CHECK ON THAT, THANK YOU,
SEAN.
GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS.
ALL RIGHT, I'M LAURA INGRAHAM
AND "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" FROM
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
SKIPPING TO 2024, THAT'S THE
FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
NOW FRANTICALLY TRYING TO SHAKE
OFF HIS LAME DUCK STATUS,
JOE BIDEN'S BUSY RALLYING
SUPPORT IN THE SENATE.
HEADLINE IN THE HILL TELLS THE
STORY, DEMOCRATIC SENATOR SAY
BIDEN IS NOT TOO OLD FOR A
SECOND TERM.
SENATORS ARE TRYING TO SOUND
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THE SOON TO
BE OCTOGENARIAN.
GREG KUHN SAID I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING HARD FOR JOE BIDEN IN
2024.
COME ON.
BOB CASEY PREDICTED HE IS TO BE
THE NOMINEE AND HE'S GOING TO BE
STRONG.
BUT THEY KNOW WHAT WE KNOW, COME
ON.
THERE IS NO MOMENTUM OUT THERE.
AT THE RISK OF POLITICAL RIGOR
MORTIS HOLDS OVER BIDEN,
ATTENTIONS ALREADY TURNING TO
THE FIELD OF THE 2024
CONTENDERS.
FIRST OFF, KAMALA HARRIS.
IF YOU'RE DOING THE PROS AND
CONS, THE ONLY PRO I CAN THINK
OF IS THAT SHE KNOWS HER WAY
AROUND THE WEST BRING TO MY
CLAIM.
IT OTHER THAN THAT'S, SHE'S BEEN
A TOTAL BOMB.
THEY MADE HEARD THE DE FACTO
BORDER CHIEF THEM A RUMOR THAT?
WHAT DOES SHE HAVE TO SHOW FOR
IT?
3 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
ENCOUNTERED AND APPREHENDED
ENTERING THE UNITED STATES
ILLEGALLY FROM 150 COUNTRIES.
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF COURSE
AVOIDS THE BORDER SUBJECT
ALTOGETHER.
REFUSING TO ADDRESS THE HUGE
UPTICK IN THE LEGAL BORDER
CROSSERS AND THE NUMBER JUST
OVER THE LAST SIX MONTHS.
THE NUMBERS BY THE WAY ARE NOT
SLOWING DOWN.
THE FIRST FIVE MONTHS OF THIS
YEAR ALONE, MORE THAN 1 MILLION
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ENCOUNTERED OR
APPREHENDED ENTERING THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
THEY TOTAL MORE THAN THE
INDIVIDUAL POPULATION OF
DELAWARE, SOUTH DAKOTA,
NORTH DAKOTA, ALASKA, THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA, VERMONT,
AND WYOMING.
WELL, AT THIS POINT, HOW IS THIS
CALLED ANYTHING BUT AN ONGOING
INVASION OF THE UNITED STATES?
>> HISTORIC NUMBERS HERE.
239,000, 416 ILLEGAL CROSSINGS.
THAT'S NOW THE HIGHEST NUMBER IN
DH AS HISTORY, 100,699 TITLE 42
EXPULSIONS REPRESENTING ONLY
ABOUT 42% OF THE TOTAL AND THERE
WAS A STAGGERING 14,699
UNCOMMITTED CHILDREN.
UP TO 21% OVER APRIL.
>> EXTREME PROGRESS WAS BEING
MADE AT THE BORDER.
>> SHE'S HONESTLY USELESS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY SHE'S IN THE
POSITION.
SHE HASN'T BEEN HERE IN SOUTH
TEXAS TO SEE.
TO SEE WHAT THE POLICIES ARE
CREATING COME OF THE MESS THAT
THEY ARE CREATING IN OUR
COUNTRY.
THEIR POLICIES ARE HURTING REAL
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: OUR PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT, THEY ARE ALL FOR
THIS.
IN A SANE WORLD, THE SUBVERSION
OF OUR SOVEREIGNTY WOULD BE AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE, BUT IN
KAMALA LAND, ITS GROUND FOR A
PROMOTION IN 2024.
WE HAVEN'T EVEN TOUCHED ON HER
EXTENSIVE GAFFES.
>> WE HAVE TO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSES OF
WHY PEOPLE LEAVE.
THE ROOT CAUSES ARE BASED ON THE
PROBLEMS AND THE CHALLENGES THAT
PEOPLE ARE FACING.
>> A DIPLOMATIC TEST TURN TO
POLITICAL.
>> HER ALLIES IN THE WHITE HOUSE
AND ELSEWHERE ARE WATCHING IT
THAN JUST KIND OF WONDERING WHAT
IS GOING ON?
>> WE'VE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
>> YOU HAVEN'T BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
>> AND I HAVEN'T BEEN TO EUROPE.
>> SOME OF WHAT SHE SAID ON THE
TRIP WERE ANSWERS TO QUESTIONS.
THOSE ANSWERS HAD WHITE HOUSE
INSIDERS PERPLEXED.
>> I'M HERE STANDING HERE ON THE
NORTHERN FLANK, THE EASTERN
FLANK TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE HAVE
IN TERMS OF THE EASTERN FLANK
AND OUR NATO ALLIES.
>> VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
ON A VISIT TO POLAND CAME UNDER
CRITICISM.
>> A FRIEND IN NEED IS A FRIEND
INDEED.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Laura: IN AN ATTEMPT TO
EXPAND HER IMPRESSIVE RESUME OF
FAILURES, KAMALA HARRIS IS
TAKING ON YET ANOTHER ROLE, ONE
THAT WILL DO NOTHING TO HELP THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN.
BUT WILL BURNERS HER LEFT WING
BONA FIDES.
I GIVE YOU KAMALA HARRIS,
INFORMATION AND SURVEILLANCE
ARE.
>> WE CONTINUE TO SEE HOW SOME
ACTS OF MASS VIOLENCE HAVE
FOLLOWED EXPRESSIONS OF ONLINE
HATE AND ABUSE.
THIS TASK FORCE WILL TACKLE A
THREAT THAT'S BEEN FAR TOO REAL
FOR FAR TOO MANY PEOPLE FOR FAR
TOO LONG.
IT WILL LEAD TO MORE EVIDENCE
INFORMED POLICIES AND
INTERVENTION.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD, IS
ANYBODY MORE ANNOYING THAT HER
DELIVERY THERE?
THE WHITE HOUSE HAD TIME FOR THE
BIG ROLLOUT TODAY OF THIS NEW
TASK FORCE.
IT'S ON ONLINE HARASSMENT AND
ABUSE, WHICH YOU MAY BE A KIND
OF QUICK TO DISMISS, JUST A
WARMED OVER DHS THIS INFORMATIOS
INFORMATION BOARD.
SPEED NINE COMES WITH BIG
GUNS INCLUDING THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL, THE
WHITE HOUSE GENDER POLICY
COUNCIL, THE SURGEON GENERAL,
AND EVEN THE DOJ IS PROMISING TO
GET INVOLVED.
>> THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS
HERE TO TAKE PLACE -- TO TAKE
ITS ROLE, TAKE PART IN THE
CRITICAL WORK OF THIS
TASK FORCE.
WE WILL PUBLISH AN ANNUAL REPORT
OF DISINFORMATION AND ALL THE
INFORMATION THAT WE GATHER TO
FURTHER INFORM OUR ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS.
>> Laura: THIS INCLUDES
EFFORTS TO POLICE LANGUAGE TO
EFFECTIVELY INSULATE POLITICAL
FIGURES AND JOURNALISTS FROM
DISINFORMATION, ABUSE, AND
HARASSMENT.
SO, BIDEN DOJ REFUSES TO
INVESTIGATE ACTUAL ABUSE AND
HARASSMENT ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
WHICH IS CLEAR DOMESTIC
TERRORISM, BUT THEIR PLEDGING
MONEY AND MANPOWER TO
CRIMINALIZE THE EXPRESSION OF
SPEECH OF THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS?
I HAVE TO ASK LIST TONIGHT, YOU
HEARD MERRICK GARLAND THERE.
WHAT ACTUALLY CONSTITUTES ABUSE
AND HARASSMENT?
WHO MAKES THE CALL?
TO THESE PEOPLE REFUSING TO USE
I DON'T KNOW, PREFERRED GENDER
PRONOUNS, THAT WOULD CONSTITUTE
A HATE CRIME.
AND AGAIN, ACTUAL ACTS OF
VIOLENCE AGAINST THEIR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS ARE DOWNPLAYED OR THEY
ARE JUST IGNORED ALTOGETHER.
>> TODAY'S EPIDEMIC OF HATE
WHICH IS FUELING VIOLENT ACTS
AGAINST MANY COMMUNITIES.
WE MUST TEACH IT AS IT REALLY
HAPPENED.
WE CAN FIGHT IGNORANCE.
DISPEL MISINFORMATION.
AND WORK TOWARD A FUTURE WHERE
ALL PEOPLE CAN LIVE WITHOUT
FEAR.
>> Laura: LIVE WITHOUT FEAR?
WHAT KIND OF UTOPIA SHE LIVING
IN?
WHO GETS TO DETERMINE WHAT IS
AND WHAT IS NOT MISINFORMATION?
THAT'S NOT THE GOVERNMENT'S
ROLE.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT, IT SURE AS
HECK PROTECTS POLITICAL SPEECH
ABSOLUTELY.
HATE ONLY CUTS ONE WAY.
IN KAMALA TOWN.
WITHOUT FAIL, THE CHOICE BETWEEN
PROTECTING OUR FREEDOM AND
CATERING TO ANTI-AMERICAN
FANATICS OF OUR OWN PARTY,
KAMALA WILL ALWAYS CHOOSE THE
LATTER.
BUT LUCKY FOR US, THE BEST WAY
TO ENSURE THE FAILURE OF ANY
TASK FORCE IS TO PROTECT HER
FROM HER EMBARRASSING ON CAMERA
PERFORMANCES.
IF KAMALA WOULD BE A VERY, VERY
RISKY BET FOR THE POST BIDEN.
NO WONDER SO MANY AND HER PARTY
ARE ALREADY LOOKING FOR AN
OFF-RAMP.
GETTING ANOTHER GADFLY COME UP
PETE BUTTIGIEG AND CENTER STAGE.
THEY END UP CANCELING EACH OTHER
OUT?
YOU'VE GOT TO WONDER.
IF SO, WEIGHTS, IF THEY CANCEL
EACH OTHER OUT TO COME UP WITH
WHEN I THINK IT WOULD MEAN?
>> MY NAME IS JOE BIDEN, I'M
JOE BIDEN'S HUSBAND.